on va parler de jean luc mélenchon si
vous voulez bien nos confrères du monde
ont révélé une note signée par 42 cadres
et militants insoumis qui se plaignent
d'une grande verticalité en termes de
décisions collectives ça je pense que ça
veut dire en bon français que c'est
mélenchon qui décide tout seul il ya des
parlementaires qui ont exprimé leurs
réticences sur la ligne qui est suivi
par exemple clémentine autain on en
parlera et puis surtout il ya toutes ces
interrogations
après la contre-performance de la liste
de la france insoumise aux dernières
élections européennes certains ont
demandé le départ de mélenchon comme
comme laurent wauquiez a pu quitter son
poste avait dans une circonstance assez
proche finalement en terme de résultat
électoral
ce n'est pas l'avis de tout le monde je
vous en fait je vous propose en écouter
deux d'abord alexis corbière le député
de la seine-saint-denis qui était ce
matin sur france info qui est membre de
la france insoumise et qui demande de ne
pas zapper trop vite mélenchon l'analyse
un peu fainéante qui consiste à dire le
problème c'est mélenchon il faut sortir
la france dont celui du moment mélenchon
et c'est franchement c'est une illusion
qui est un peu courte de mon point de
vue il faut par contre une fois de plus
réfléchir sur qu'est ce qu'on fait à
l'avenir appartient qui est le mieux
placé si je puis dire pour le faire jean
luc est quand même a été quand même une
locomotive notre mouvement c'est lui qui
l'a porté hier
ne soyons pas à perth était ya pas si
longtemps 2010 cei si on vous écoute
bien ils s'interrogent aujourd'hui sur
le rôle qu'il peut jouer jean luc
mélenchon oui monsieur je pose des
questions il a le droit je veux dire il
a le droit
en fait cette cette réserve avec lacets
générale 1 chez les responsables de la
france insoumise en tout cas quand les
micros sont ouverts même clémentine
autain donc les députés la france est
soumise elle aussi de seine-saint-denis
qui avait été très critique sur la ligne
suivie par le parti pendant
les élections européennes ne demandent
pas le départ de mélenchon elle l'a dit
ce matin sur rtl
ce que je demande c'est pas le retrait
de jean luc mélenchon c'est de bien
mesurer la ligne et de changer
d'orientation politique il est capable
de la flotte a fait ce jeu c'est
possible de le faire je me souviens
qu'il y a deux ans il a eu un profil
politique rassembleur qui nous a hissé
très haut
voilà donc je peux pas vous le dire plus
clairement c'est que c'est que c'est
l'ensemble de l'orientation de tout le
monde si vous dites on se sépare de jean
luc mélenchon il n'est plus notre leader
mais que vous avez la même ligne
politique je ne suis pas sûr qu'on ait
énormément progressé offrir à tous c'est
quoi une question de l'élection de
personnes ou est ce qu'on peut vraiment
séparer les deux compliqué il ya
beaucoup de choses qui s'enchevêtrent le
le problème c'est que en fait clémentine
autain a posé la question de la ligne
juste après les élections et le débat
s'est quasiment entièrement concentré
sur la ligne des insoumis trop union de
la gauche ou trop populiste selon les
avis or ce qui est vrai c'est que ces
questions de ligne est quand même peu de
gens qu'ils en sont conscients des
risques et les gens s politiques et les
gens qui eut de très près les politiques
mais le gros des électeurs ne saisit pas
trop ces noms cela alors sur la question
de mélenchon je pense que les facteurs
de la défaite des insoumis aux
européennes en parties sont liées à sa
personne en partie non il ya des
éléments qui ne sont pas de son ressort
terre que traditionnellement ce sont des
mots aux élections pour la gauche
radicale puisque son électorat
s'abstient lors de ces élections et on
peut aussi penser qu'en 2017 et vu
beaucoup de votes utiles sur la personne
mélenchon parce que c'était le candidat
le mieux placé à gauche
du coup il ya beaucoup de sympathisants
socialistes plus modérés qui avaient
voté pour lui et qu'il a sont revenus
sur europe écologie les verts ou les
socialistes mais par contre il ya des
éléments qui sont directement liés à
mélenchon pour beaucoup de gens
mélenchon aujourd'hui c'est les
perquisitions c'est son attitude pendant
les perquisitions
c'est le bruit et la fureur et donc en
vérité on peut se poser la question de
incertain rejette mélenchon surtout qui
s'est impliqué pendant cette campagne
mais de l'autre côté la france soumise
c'est mélenchon en le succès de la
france est soumise en 2017 c'est la
figure de mélenchon et c'est lui qui
l'incarnent de personnes les autres un
semis sont pas très connus et ils n'ont
pas sa dimension donc c
vraiment une une équation très
compliquée à résoudre pour lui ça qu'il
va pouvoir tenir olivier ravanello c'est
juste un mauvais moment à passer
mais je pense que la vraie question
c'est de savoir ce qu'ils veulent aux
prochaines élections c'est à dire ce
qu'ils veulent être à 6 ou 7 ce qui est
de mon point de vue et leur corpus
naturel idéologique et la réserve de ce
courant de pensée aujourd'hui dans un
pays où est-ce qu'ils ambitionnent de
pouvoir remonter à 17,18 peut-être plus
est le seul qui est capable de faire
monter la mayonnaise on l'a vu durant la
campagne c'est mélenchon
il a un talent il a un charisme il a un
talent d'orateur il a une capacité à
élargir son socle y compris par des
alliances politiques que n'ont pas les
autres donc le choix est là après que
mélenchon soit insupportable sens
littéral du terme
oui il est insupportable par les gens
qui travaillent avec lui mais il est
insupportable parce que c'est le
ressorte son engagement politique il
parle aux gens qui ne supportent plus la
situation donc mélenchon est quelqu'un
d' insupportable mais c'est le seul à
les faire monter à 17 à 18 la question
du jour sur le figaro.fr
après les mauvais scores de la france
insoumise aux européennes jean-luc
mélenchon doit-il se mettre en retrait
du parti et 88 % des internautes du
figaro répondent oui c'est ce que c'est
pour le bien de la france en demi de
crise et il est insupportable
je pense qu'il a surestimé le concept
d'insoumission y partie d'un point de
vue qui était de considérer que
finalement il y avait aujourd'hui un
potentiel de colère dans le pays qui est
tel que il va le porter d'une manière
irréversible au pouvoir ça c'est la
thèse de mélenchon en même temps il est
quand même très réaliste il sait ce que
c'est qu'un rapport de force politique
continue quand même de son parcours mais
je pense qu'il ya d'autres problèmes
au delà de sa personnalité au delà de sa
communication en effet une communication
cad kick ass pardon les codes du
politiquement correct
au delà de son attitude lors de la
fameuse perquisition ya un problème de
ligne politique aussi à la france a
soumis c'est à dire que finalement quand
on regarde de près vous avez deux lignes
à la france est soumise
vous avez une ligne qui est plutôt
populiste souverainiste et puis vous
avez une autre ligne qui est incarnée
entre autres par madame autain ou par
madame au bono qui est plus sociétale
voir indices
nist et la difficulté c'est que
finalement jean luc mélenchon qui est un
nombre de synthèse aussi à sa façon en
tout cas dans ce dans cet espace
politique n'a pas véritablement orbite
ray ou lorsqu'il a arbitré ou lorsqu'il
arbitrer il a plutôt donné l'impression
d'arbitré contre les souverainistes que
contre gelé la ligne la ligne les
communautaristes donc je pense qu'il
paye aussi d'une certaine façon
l'ambiguïté qui est la sienne à
l'intérieur de sa propre formation
politique il a certainement brouiller
des messages et encore une fois c'est
quelqu'un qui avait un potentiel et qui
peut être encore un potentiel électoral
qui est assez important mais qui
manifestement n'a pas su arbitrer entre
des lignes politiques qui à mon sens
sont assez opposées finalement à
l'intérieur d'une même maison qu'il faut
arbitrer
est ce que mitterrand est pas dans la
même situation est-ce que ce qui lui
permet de gagner c'est justement de ne
pas arbitrer à un moment donné sur une
élection qui focalise sur sa personne de
réunir tout le monde
le problème c'est que il a donné le
sentiment d'arbitré on voit bien que la
façon dont il a traité notamment un
certain nombre de souverainistes à
l'intérieur de la formation politique en
nonne écurité d'ailleurs éjecté donne le
sentiment que finalement pour des
raisons électorales really est
certainement à l'implantation électorale
d'un certain nombre de ses députés
il a plutôt arbitré d'iso dans le sens
par dans le sens et gérer nos paradoxes
dans le sens de madame hauteur et qui
aujourd'hui finalement le critique sur
sa ligne politique
donc je pense qu'il a aussi cette
difficulté qui explique en partie pas
seulement les déboires électoraux qu'il
a pu rencontrer lors de cette élection
c'est aussi la vôtre avis et là c'est la
ligne prise par le parti danseuse
européenne puisque la personne de
jean-luc mélenchon qui a été sanctionné
oui je suis plutôt effectivement de cet
avis c'est à dire que le
incontestablement ils se posent à la
france est soumise à un véritable enjeu
de savoir sur quelle base sociologique
ils vont s'appuyer pour pouvoir faire le
score le plus élevé possible et que
l'une des possibilités qui s'offrent à
eux
c'est d'essayer de capter de mobiliser
d'abord et puis d'essayer de le capter
l'électorat d'origine immigrée le
problème c'est que ça rotrou sa présente
évidemment pour pour eux un vrai risque
parce qu'évidemment cet électorat là il
n'est pas a priori véritablement géré
compatible avec les thèses avec les
thèses
et publics n bon d'une part et puis et
puis évidemment il ya la question de la
dérive
d'après certains vers le populisme parce
qu'évidemment défendre le peuple contre
je dirais les élites et bien ça peut
peut-être les conduira à la verse
prendre position de manière plus ferme
sur les questions d'immigration ou
peut-être même et pour des
internationalistes c'est quand même
compliqué peut être même avoir à opter
ou à se prononcer sur la question du
protectionnisme
donc ça je crois qu'il ya la question du
discours mais je crois qu'il ya eu aussi
une autre question c'est qu'ils sont
tombés des nues tout simplement c'est
que bien sûr la crise à la france
insoumise coup parce qu'on sait bien
comment ça fonctionne
il ya la structure nationale qui est
extrêmement refermer et puis les
structures locales qui elles sont
parfaitement libres mais les structures
locales n'ont aucune influence
normalement sur ceux qui dirigent la
france insoumise donc ça couve depuis un
certain temps mais il est bien évident
que ça éclate aujourd'hui en raison des
résultats parce qu'ils se sont pris à
rêver
il pensait qu'il pesait à eux seuls 20%
il n'était pas loin de ça aux
présidentielles de statut présidentiel
et que c était captée par une
personnalité talentueuse un tribun
populaire effectivement un tribun de la
plèbe qui est qu'est jean luc mélenchon
mais je suis au regret de leur dire que
depuis la chute du mur de berlin
le collectivisme est en train de
régresser et que la force je dirais
politique elle ne vient plus au flex pas
nous y semant politique le dynamisme
politique ne vient plus par la gauche et
que si on additionne toutes les listes
de gauche aux européennes ou si on a des
listes ou si on additionne tous les
candidats de gauche à la présidentielle
eh bien ils pèsent 25% et pas plus alors
je fais deux éléments sur l'acte aurait
migré je suis en désaccord parce que je
pense que la ligne alors moi je
l'appellerai pas indigéniste trouve ça
un petit peu et série all away mais je
l'appellerai gauchistes plus tôt je
pense qu'elle séduit plus il peut une
bourgeoisie robben que justement les
électeurs émigrés qui souvent sont très
républicain d'ailleurs il ya des
électeurs ceux qui se déplacent mais
justement s'ils veulent essayer de
mobiliser ceux qui ne se déplace pas oui
mais je suis pas sûr qu'ils se
mobilisent sur un défaut communautariste
par exemple alexis corbière est
quelqu'un de très républicain il est élu
en seine-saint-denis deuxième élément
je pense qu'il ya pour le coup un sujet
sur lequel tout le monde est d'accord au
sein de la france en ce mu c'est le
manque de démocratie interne au
mouvement et les départs de cadres ne
sont pas dû qu'à des questions d'une
politique mais aussi assez manque de
démocratie interne qui a renvoyé
mauvaise image babineau un internaute
fidèles nous dit qu on fait la même
erreur avec jean luc mélenchon qu'avec
marine le pen elle a survécu à sa lourde
défaite des présidentielles mélenchon
aussi un peu sur grives les idées
qu'elle marine le pen je pense quelle
manière elle n'a pas tué le
rassemblement national mais si en
revanche marie le pen s'entête à vouloir
être la candidate du rassemblement
national le débat et la
décrédibilisation de sa personne lors du
débat de 2017 va lui revenir en
boomerang
la comparaison mélange gens le prennent
la résilience de marine le pen marine le
pen elle est liée à la résilience d'une
formation politique il ya plus de 40 ans
d'âge aussi il faut qu'elle me voir ça
aussi si vous voulez la france est
soumise est une formation politique une
offre politique récente n'a pas la même
histoire que celle du rassemblement
national
donc ça je crois que c'est un premier
point le deuxième point c'est que
l'échec de marine le pen était un échec
relatif à la présidentielle c'est
l'échec surtout de son débat qui a
profondément marqué mais quand on
regarde quand même le résultat elle est
présente au second tour elle progresse
même en voix et en pourcentage entre les
deux tours et force est de constater que
les résultats de l'élection européenne
sont plutôt quand même même s'ils ne
sont pas peut être à la hauteur des
espérances de marine le pen et de l'état
major du rassemblement national plutôt
en progression
donc je crois pas qu'on puisse
véritablement faire une comparaison
entre marine le pen et jean luc
mélenchon d'autant plus que du côté de
marine le pen
il n'y a pas de discussion à l'intérieur
aujourd'hui du rassemblement national
sur la ligne aujourd'hui je dis bien
aujourd'hui sur la ligne politique parce
que c'est yannick jadot qui griffe
ferait aussi de l'ombre à jean luc
mélenchon vous le disiez adria matois en
mélenchon c'était la seule alternative à
gauche aujourd'hui c'est plus le cas
alors je suis très sceptique sur la
pérennité du vote écolo parce que je
pense que la majorité bon score à 2 13%
alors dérobé dit avait fait seize noms
mais déjà quand on dit très bon score 13
% oui déjà
et ensuite la moitié des 13 % sont des
décisions dans la dernière semaine et
sur une campagne qui a vraiment tourné
autour du thème de l'écologie est
aujourd'hui en plus yannick jadot se
réclament pas du tout de la gauche et
même un discours social quasiment
inexistant donc je pense qu'il est plus
sur un créneau modéré que jean luc
mélenchon il ya très peu discours social
dans ce que les ninjas devait servir de
supplétif macro c'est une hypothèse
violences et de divisions aussi oui oui
on néglige apprenait que les gauchistes
et les pragmatiques le débat n'est pas
tranché
vous avez esquissé les uns et les autres
cette différence de positionnement entre
la france insoumise pendant la campagne
présidentielle de 2017 plutôt populiste
souverainiste et puis la france
insoumise plus communautariste ou
gauchiste apparemment ça leur réussit
pas est ce qu'on peut imaginer un
nouveau un nouveau coup de barre
idéologique pour changer un peu le
positionnement l'idée ravanello ça vous
paraît moi je continue de penser qu'il
ya ces deux familles et que mélenchon a
été capable de les réunir donc il va
être capable de deux de fer d'avant
regarder le score du regarder le score
du parti communiste aux dernières
élections européennes
ou mélenchon est capable à un moment
donné sur une présidentielle de prendre
tout le monde et vous ajoutez on tombe à
peu près sur les 17 18 et je pense que
c'est le maximum de ce qu'ils peuvent
faire
mais ça peut suffire à se retrouver un
deuxième tour mais si vous n'avez pas la
personnalité de mélenchon et vous n'avez
que des corbières que d autun et c'est
cette synthèse
ils arriveront pas le faire au sein de
la france est soumise il ya quand même à
parquer mondiale au teint qui était très
offensive sur le retour à une union de
la gauche il ya quand même quasiment
tous les ténors de 4 nasa corbières en
passant par coquerel qui en prenait pour
le un retour quand même l hymne populis
de 2017
oui enfin si l'objectif de si l'objectif
de jean luc mélenchon est de conquérir
l'elysée
ce qui à mon avis reste son objectif il
faudra bien qu'à un moment donné il
arrive à avoir une alliance avec les
sociaux démocrates
et c'est là que se pose le problème
c'est que je ne vois pas aujourd'hui de
zone de convergence entre quand même les
sociaux-démocrates et l'idéologie de la
soumission ça me paraît assez compliqué
à ce stade mais justement dans la dans
la stratégie populiste s'est passé et
coloré qui sont et qui sont visés quoi